i gotta ask okay there's there's one
thing i do want to hear why you did it
okay watching avatar on stream
okay we're bringing out the hard
questions now we're bringing out the
heart so this isn't god's first rodeo
you know
you did it previously
on twitch
metas are
very very common right okay
there is a among us meta fortnight meta
and meta just means like what is most
popular what is really bringing
viewership et cetera et cetera right if
you want to be a streamer that has a
very very long
lifespan and career you must change with
the times at least to some degree
twitch had gotten to a point where they
weren't personally um like banning
people for playing copyrighted content
yeah they
they were essentially like a safe haven
for that kind of thing and they forced
the copyright holder to take down that
content themselves right
and so what happened was you had major
very very large streamers like toast as
you said xqc like everybody just started
watching flat out tv shows and movies
and whatever yeah he watched um
death note yeah yeah i think he watched
naruto as well
yeah so you had these people watching
all these shows and
miss kiff also watched the avatar on
stream yeah so obviously to me i'm like
oh these people
watched things let me watch
the same thing that someone has already
streamed right to a similar sized
audience as me yeah
but i got hit with the dude
and then the pirating messages
what i wanted to know was like did you
all did you all know that you were just
like okay we're gonna wait for the first
person to get here and then we're gonna
stop afterwards okay yeah legit right it
was basically like oh this is a
normalized thing
right at this point
um so even like yeah it was just a
a tricky thing
if uh if we watched anime in japan we'd
go to jail yeah we're doing it on stream
because because fair use is not a law
yeah i'm abusing copywriters like they
they really go after it there yeah uh
but i i think for us it was kind of like
what the [ __ ] is happening because
because you know a lot of the time we've
worked with japanese corporations and we
were trying to build up that bridge of
like nah youtubers and twitch they're
not scary come on just like work with us
and then it was like please don't look
at what is happening please please stay
on youtube it's like these ain't our
mans they say no man they are not like
us
because it was like oh my god this good
will that we're trying to bring another
because their show like what these
companies are so scared
i think i worked with crunchyroll on
something and they are like very
i mean and it's not even themselves it
comes to handling the actors yeah yeah
yeah because it's not very strict them
half the time that that like why they're
scared it's like because they have the
japanese people breathing down their
neck just being like you if you [ __ ] up
we are gonna pull the show yeah yeah
yeah yeah
which is again very understandable and
honestly i felt really bad about that
because like
it was the apology video yeah
that's where you should have made an
apology video about and then i would
have watched it on stream and [ __ ]
laughed at you
abusing copywriting no joke why didn't
you make an apology video so we could
have
it's like you have so many other even
larger streamers than me doing this
thing and as soon as i do it i'm the one
who i i was honestly i was really
appalled mainly with uh twitch i
couldn't believe that they left how
inconsistent
they just say copyright holder if you
find it then it's on you to tell us and
then we'll take it down it just yeah it
just felt like it was like because i
mean we were all on youtube before the
adpocalypse yeah we were just like it
was just like vietnam flashbacks like oh
no oh here we go
oh no here we go
oh [ __ ] people on twitch were worried
about that too luckily that's not what
ended up happening yeah um i feel like
something's gonna happen do you think
there's an inevitably inevitability that
something like that is going to happen
on twitch
because i don't think anyone expected it
to happen on youtube until it happened
no everyone's really cool it's well
established enough that it likely won't
however i do think we're heading into a
recession i mean we're tech
receptionists
you know sorry i was gonna say i think
because of that we might see similar
things of like
not as many sponsorships not as many
crazy ad rates yeah so it might almost
feel like an adpocalypse but it won't
have anything to do with the platform
the entire world is going through an ad
apocalypse right now
it's like yo what are we getting like
inflation you're like
did they crazy i do think i mean am i
doing who feels like content creators
have been a little bit um
overvalued for like a year or two
like some things are just like maybe
you're at the top though you're at the
top so you get the premiums yeah yeah
yeah we're we're little bottom feeders
guys they're in a million billion
dollars like a million billion a million
billion dollar man
talking about
that that's that's our patrons man thank
you very much patrons by the way
yeah we have to fight tooth and nails
for like any company's like to take us
seriously yeah
you guys are like a really cool
especially in japan though
yeah yeah you think we're you know we're
doing pretty good yeah
you need to hit up people in america
yeah that's why like i felt here in l.a
everyone's just like yes yes king say
what you want yes what do you what you
know like what do you want to say what
do you want to do how do you want to
work together yeah like in japan it's
just like why are you here at my door
like
who's why are you on your knees begging
yeah who is this random sassy child
that's just appeared right i'm sorry do
you speak japanese i didn't think so
yeah exactly right exactly exactly yeah
it's been a totally different it's it's
almost been like a culture shock yeah
just seeing how yeah the infrastructure
is totally different than combini's
though
you can you can watch this uh podcast on
stream if you want by the way that's
okay really yeah
okay
people do it all the time what are we
going to cop you strike your own
i was just joking but yeah yeah
i will and then we'll make a special
video where we where we just go around
copy striking yeah all of your streams
well when as long as we can react to you
reacting to this then then it's all good
when i did a
sabbath on and i went to bed i just
played episode of trash taste that's all
i did oh that's really nice cause i was
like i can't believe i can't believe
you've been breaking out copyright it's
two and a half hours of content yeah and
i can't there's so [ __ ] much so many
yeah
legit why would you watch avatar when
you could just watch all of trash taste
right there's way more content
caught up exactly the same kind of
content actually exactly it's just one
is a bit longer
yeah just as much lauren trashton
character development
i'm just saying the trash tastes better
that's going to be the next one
everyone should stop watching masterchef
yeah there was a gordon ramsay yeah
there was that was the one watching tv
shows and movies almost got like
normalized and they're like effort anime
yeah yeah i wonder who is the first one
to be like you know what [ __ ] it let's
just watch [ __ ] whole tv shows let's
just do it i forget i was it was uh xqc
wasn't i watching master jeff i thought
i thought it started with like him
watching masterchef no i think a lot of
other people watched masterchef before
he did right but i don't know who like
took it that step further and did
animate mind you can i just say like
it was you know ecstasy toast it is me
we all did a lot of people did it and so
many other streamers were like okay it's
time to watch it
which doesn't make it okay
but just to say like i think a lot of
people
assume if something isn't being punished
and it's like it seems permissible right
even if it's not okay